vamos a probar otra de las propiedades
de los logaritmos porque ya me gustó
esto si utilizamos las potencias y los
exponentes podemos lograr demostrar
todas las propiedades de los logaritmos
así que vamos a escribir aquí lo que
siempre sabemos yo sé que el logaritmo
en base a en base x de a es igual a b
esto quiere decir en lenguaje de
exponentes que x elevado a la potencia p
es igual a esto ya lo hemos visto varias
veces es la expresión equivalente y de
aquí voy a partir x elevado a la b es
igual a am y esto me va a servir para
demostrar la tercera propiedad de los
logaritmos a ver qué pasa si yo
multiplico esto por se lo voy a
multiplicar por ser ceesem es una letra
bastante interesante así que voy a
multiplicar esto por cm pero como
multiplico esto por c pues hay que
multiplicarlo de ambos lados de esta
igualdad para que se mantenga la
igualdad y que me va a quedar pues c
veces el logaritmo en base x
cbc es el logaritmo en base x de am esto
es igual a cbc sven es decir se por b
recuerda que hay que multiplicar por
ambos lados de la ecuación b por c
por b muy bien hasta aquí ya tengo esta
propiedad ahora voy a esperar un poco
porque lo que quiero hacer a
continuación es lo que tengo aquí del
lado derecho es a trabajarlo pero
elevando a la c va a ser distinto lo que
voy a hacer aquí a continuación es
elevar a la potencia y que me quedan
pues si elevó a la potencia se me va a
quedar del lado izquierdo x elevado al
haber elevado la potencia cm vamos a
escribirlo aquí
x elevado al haber elevado a su vez a la
sep y del lado derecho pues me queda ha
elevado la cem pero aquí voy a utilizar
una de las propiedades de los exponentes
yo sé que tengo algo elevado a una
potencia y después elevado a otra
potencia las potencias se multiplican
por lo tanto esto me va a quedar x
elevado al ave x
entonces déjenme escribirlo por aquí
esto va a implicar que utilizando las
propiedades de los exponentes esto es lo
mismo que x elevado a la b por c igual
ha elevado a la cem y bueno ahora bien
qué te parece si esto mismo yo escribo
en lenguaje de logaritmos ya sabemos
escribir las cosas que tienen que ver
con exponentes en lenguaje de logaritmos
así que lo que voy a hacer a
continuación escribir esto mismo con la
expresión de los logaritmos y me
quedaría algo así el logaritmo en base x
de ha elevado a la sen esto es igual a b
x se me recuerda a que potencia tengo
que llevar a x para que me dé ha elevado
a la cem y la respuesta después de la
potencia de porsche entonces esto es
igual a b por cm y qué creés ya logré la
tercera propiedad de los logaritmos
porque darte cuenta de lo siguiente aquí
tengo por cm y aquí tengo también b por
cm lo que quiere decir que esta parte de
aquí tiene que ser exactamente igual a
esta parte de aquí o dicho de otra
manera ya llega a la tercera propiedad
de los logaritmos c veces el logaritmo
en base x
esto tiene que ser igual al logaritmo
envase x de elevado las dos cosas
iguales a una tercera son iguales entre
sí vamos a escribirlo seis veces el
logaritmo en base x de amd esto tiene
que ser igual porque lo acabamos de ver
de porsche pero b por c es igual a
logaritmo en base x de ha elevado a la
cem por lo tanto ya se cumple mi
igualdad y aquí tengo mi tercera
propiedad de los logaritmos el primer
axioma de euclides y ya con esto
logramos esta demostración así que vamos
a recordar todo lo que hemos visto hasta
ahorita todo lo que hemos demostrado y
vamos a intentar hacer una nueva
demostración a ver lo primero que
hicimos en este vídeo fue decir si
nosotros tenemos a veces el logaritmo en
base x déjame ponerlo aquí seis veces el
logaritmo en base x de amd esto es igual
a logaritmo en base x de ha elevado al
hacer esto lo acabamos de mostrar hace
menos de un minuto y en el vídeo pasado
vimos la demostración de la suma de
logaritmos recuerda
habíamos dicho que si nosotros tomamos
el logaritmo envase x de am más el
logaritmo en base x de b
esto es igual al logaritmo en base x de
borbén
los podemos pasar multiplicando y bueno
si tú haces un poco de memoria acerca de
las propiedades de los logaritmos que
pasaba sé quién me dio en lugar de un
más tengo un menos bueno si yo tengo un
menos lo que pasaba es que en lugar de
pasar multiplicando a por ver lo que
pasaba era dividiendo dividimos el que
era positivo entre el que ha negativo es
decir a entre 20 y de hecho es lo que
quiero demostrar en este tiempo que me
queda así que vamos a seguir con la
misma idea que vimos en el vídeo pasado
podría decir que el logaritmo en base x
de amd es igual a l y voy a bautizar
como el logaritmo envase x de b como m y
recuerdas más o menos que hicimos
también bautizamos como el logaritmo en
base x de entre b a n el logaritmo en
base x deja entrever a n y entonces
dijimos bueno si esto es cierto entonces
x elevado a la l es igual a vamos a
ponerlo aquí x elevado a la l
mientras que por otra parte x elevado a
la m es igual la p de aquí tengo que x
elevado la m es igual a b y por último
de aquí de la última ecuación tengo que
x elevado a la n es exactamente lo mismo
que a entre b y de hecho de aquí voy a
partir es lo mismo que a entre b y lo
que voy a hacer a continuación es
sustituir a y sustituir a b de la sus
ecuaciones que tengo aquí arriba porque
ya sé que es lo mismo que x a la l por
lo tanto vamos a ponerlo como a es igual
a x a la l y b es igual a 10 y sale m
esto no queda x la l entre x a la m es
decir a entre 20 x a la n es igual a x a
la l entre x a la m y después de aquí
pues podemos pasar este x clm con signo
negativo recuerdas esta es una de las
propiedades de los exponentes que mejor
conocemos entonces esto me quedaría como
x a la l x x a la menos n o dicho otra
manera es lo mismo que x elevado a la l
menos m y muy parecido a lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado yo sé que por lo que
dice aquí
a la n es igual a equis a la l
m yo voy a decir que las potencias
tienen que ser iguales si quiero que se
cumpla esta igualdad es decir que n
tiene que ser igual a l menos m las
potencias tienen que ser iguales déjenme
escribirlo aquí n tiene que ser igual a
l menos n muy bien y después lo que voy
a hacer lo mismo que hice en el vídeo
pasado substituir el valor de x el
logaritmo substituir el valor de l en
logaritmos y substituir el valor de m en
logaritmos y que me va a quedar déjame
ponerlo por acá n es el logaritmo en
base x de entrever es justo como lo
bautizamos aquí abajo n es igual a
logaritmo en base xd entre bien el
logaritmo en base xd
entre b bueno después tengo el en el
eslogan ritmo en base x de a entonces
déjame ponerlo y copiando aquí el
logaritmo en base xd a el logaritmo en
base de crisis de an después tengo menos
en él pero m es el logaritmo en base x
de b lo tengo justo aquí así fue como lo
bautizamos casi por cómo lo definimos y
lo voy a poner aquí
xd ven y ya tengo demostrada la
propiedad de la diferencia de logaritmos
ya tengo la demostración enhorabuena ya
tenemos la siguiente demostración y por
lo tanto ya podemos utilizar sin miedo a
equivocarnos la propiedad que tenemos
justo aquí muy bien nos falta demostrar
solamente una cuarta propiedad que es el
cambio de base pero ya no tengo tiempo
así que lo voy a ver en el siguiente
vídeo y por lo tanto no te lo pierdas